good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday you guys
i am so excited this is first of all
like the best day of my life we are
celebrating the end of the week it's
friday and i am here doing a solo very
oprah winfrey of me talking to two of
the most important people in mine in
jackie's life right now it's jannan it's
or shaw show how do you prefer to be i
like jane and she like shocked i like
jannan i do yeah it just works
okay you guys are here in studio first
of all thank you so much for being here
like this is just we've been non-stop
talking about you guys for like the last
month this is my first go-around on the
love island journey and you guys really
made it so worthwhile so thank you so
much for doing that thank you thank you
thank you so much for having us honestly
we're huge fans um this has been like a
crazy
month for you guys obviously and
i actually like so many people in my dms
i don't know how everyone knows anything
they did spoil for me like the night
before you guys left that you were
leaving and i just like that was the
most wild turn of events first of all
how are you doing like how's your family
i'm really like that's such a hard thing
to go through yeah it's been a lot
obviously the last couple weeks you know
just with everything coming off the show
and then especially what had happened
and why we had to leave um
you know under the circumstances my
family's holding up okay obviously you
know when you transition out of a show
like this you have everything that's
going on with that and then you know i
also have you know the traumatic loss of
my sister in the same exact um equation
right there so it's been
like happy and sad at the same time and
it's kind of hard to balance those
emotions right it's like an unbelievable
high and like an earth-shattering low
exactly it's like one of the worst
things you can go through and then one
of the best things you can go through
it's crazy at the same time so i think
under the circumstances we're holding up
though okay that's good yeah and
honestly i think a lot of people were
really moved by the fact that you left
with
josh just because you know you guys were
really strong on the show but you know
the show is a show everyone's thinks
like you know what what's actually going
on so can you talk a little bit about
like how and when and why you made that
decision to go with him
yeah it really wasn't even like a second
thought um josh got the terrible news
and said you know i need chat in here
with me right now
they pulled me josh explained what
happened and
um his family was nice enough to say you
know if shannon's comfortable we would
love for her to fly back with you that's
so nice um so i was just glad that it
was an option for me because
i've never met his family you know we
don't know how we're portrayed on the
outside right
i have no idea what was aired and what
was not so
the fact that they
let me um go and fly back with josh was
huge for me um i was not gonna stay in
that villa
i was gonna come right back with josh
like me and josh had already talked like
before saying like if i were gonna to go
home or he were to go home like we were
gonna leave together of course because
we found what we were looking for at
that point and obviously i just wanted
to be there for josh it's such a hard
time like something like that i couldn't
even imagine going through so i just
wanted to be there with him and help him
throw it
and just like we were all so glad like
it was such a we feel so invested
watching the show and you're like oh my
god what and it's such a such a crazy
feeling to watch a reality show that's
happening in real time right because
we're used to watching reality shows
where like all this [ __ ] happened eight
months ago so you just feel even more
invested in the journey and i think for
a lot of people who were very invested
in your relationship we all felt you
know at peace knowing that you were
going to be there for josh it was just
it was really um it was very moving
thank you yeah it wasn't even a second
thought yeah she's been she's been
amazing throughout the whole thing like
obviously she came back with me she
didn't have to do that and then she
probably met
a million people like extended family
friends people that we don't even know
and she's just been absolutely amazing
throughout the entire thing so yeah
she's been my rock the last couple weeks
for sure oh so you guys are still
together
if you didn't you didn't know
i have a question actually i have so
many questions for you guys one about
the show and like the drama but also
about the logistics because you guys are
actively posting on social media but
it's not you guys even though you have
phones the phones are for the island and
there's someone back home running your
instagrams yes yes i definitely want to
start here so my friend i have to give
her a shout out alex kelleher she was
running my instagram back home one of my
good friends she is a huge toaster like
she's the one who yeah
crying that we were gonna get on the
show okay you should have brought her
yeah i know right i know so she would
hate me if i didn't give her a shout out
today
was running my instagram huge toaster
she's awesome so yeah so you did you
choose people or the show chose how does
that work no i chose she actually does
social media for like her job right so
and we're all good friends as a kid do
you mind like running my socials while
i'm gone she like took it she wanted to
do it she was like i don't even want
money nothing like that so do you have
to have someone running your social
media or you could choose not to post
yeah i think jeremy and cory
jeremy's instagram have you seen it
does he lift i don't know it's literally
only shirtless mirror pictures
now that he's like a public figure
somebody has to help him oh my god
somebody should have been running his
instagram hundred percent i just had my
sister run mine yeah
and i paid her for it because she's also
on social media i you just said
something really interesting when you
were saying how like you didn't know how
josh's family like what they saw so when
you're in the villa obviously you're
there to have fun you're really there to
connect but are you like worried all the
time about like how you're coming off
like did you have anxiety about that
i had anxiety the entire time right um i
feel like you're just sober all the time
but you black out like i literally would
black out during the challenges i would
black out during any um recoupling
ceremony like i don't even remember what
i said
um but
we just know going into it that their
you know um production is gonna
cut and edit any way that they want so
you're there for
you know a month now we were there
obviously something's gonna come up and
of course that one bad thing or that one
day where you're really tired like we
don't get any sleep in the villa yeah so
that's obviously going to be with the
air because it's dramatic and it makes
tv right i don't think i don't think i
was like anxious or nervous while we
were in there but then once we came out
and then we started watching like the
first two episodes and i was like that
didn't happen like that so it was giving
me anxiety like that because i didn't
know when you're in there i'm just like
oh i'm just gonna be me go with the flow
but like when you actually see how it's
all mashed together it's like for the
most part it's all there yeah you know
like we know what goes on behind the
scenes and like the conversations that
we have and other people have so it's
kind of interesting to see how it shakes
out like that yeah so funny at what
point after you left the villa after you
got your phones back like did you guys
realize like you were
really like the winners
like i'm we're all i'm very deep on love
island reddit like i'm very invested in
this whole journey you guys were winning
until you had to go home right when did
no idea like at what point did you know
like oh people loved us like we were a
fan favorite well we kind of assumed
once we had a couple like america votes
and we weren't in the bottom right right
we didn't know if we were the top but we
were just like okay america likes us a
little bit and then we didn't realize
what it was until we came out right and
we got all the support has been
absolutely amazing um the outpour people
we don't even know it's been crazy but
we didn't know it was like that until we
got out so it was pretty cool to see
yeah i also i just like how the supports
from literally all around the world like
india you name it like people in our
dm's commenting like love from canada
and all these different places it's just
it's it's amazing that people actually
like who we are is like authentic people
like yeah we went on the show saying
well we're just gonna leave it all out
on the table yeah take it or leave it
like this is how we are you can't just
go on a tv show and pretend like you're
somebody that you're not
that's
it's
a
why we got along honestly yes we were
just like being ourselves like not
really caring not trying to fake nothing
no in the beginning when you had to do
that step forward thing like was that as
awkward as it felt for us like it was so
painful like when nobody stepped forward
for like half the guys like i really
like that was me i would have left like
i would have been so offended well i was
crapping my pants because i had watched
the previous seasons and once i found
out i was going to be the first one out
there
i knew that no one steps forward for the
first person i was like i'm going to be
embarrassed on national television first
day here we go
and then i walked out and i literally
couldn't stop looking at shannon and
luckily three girls stepped forward and
she stepped forward who else stepped
forward uh kira and trina dan that's so
crazy i might have so many thoughts okay
we're gonna tell them but i need to
stick to my questions because i'm gonna
forget um okay when you guys left the
show did you watch the episodes
obviously you were busy but did you keep
up at all
uh we honestly haven't even really
dove into a lot of the episodes we
watched the first couple obviously after
you know a week went by we had a lot
going on we watched the hideaway yeah
your hideaway yeah yeah i watched it
today we had to yeah i heard a lot of uh
feedback from the hideaway and for us
this was the cbs show i didn't know what
paramount plus was baby oh is there
okay so you guys didn't really keep up
but there was a lot of
once you guys left and cash and cinco
left i do feel like
for me like the show was over um but we
were left with like these couples and i
just have so many thoughts on all of
them and i would love to hear your
guys's thoughts on the people who
eventually won which is olivia and corey
like we very much here at the morning
toast like take the stand we agree with
the whole narrative that like olivia's
an actress and like not for one second
does she like cory and corey's so in
love with her and it's so sad and he
should have taken the money for himself
what do you guys think
that's a mouthful right there um i don't
know i can speak on our behalf and say
that you know corey and olivia were two
of our good friends in there and like
what you see on tv is literally them off
camera so from our perspective i think
they genuinely do like each other um and
obviously that's from being inside and
talking to them and hanging out with
them and living with them but
i do think that it wasn't fake i think
some of the best relationships do start
as friendships and they were kind of
there they were always good friends but
you never had like a romantic
relationship and i think that as guys
started coming in or especially casa i
think is where olivia realized and you
can speak more about that where like
corey was it for her okay like she was
talking about him at casa moore yeah
because casa and more we basically were
saying like okay olivia like this is
your time to shine she was like guys
like i
think i really like cory and we were
like what what it's so random
your friend corey like but the best
relationships start out as friendships
and that's what we were saying and like
even like i facetimed olivia yesterday
and she was like she's into corey she
said it to me on the facetime she was
like so in quarry there was like i i
guess i don't know if i could spell a
little bit empty
um i guess there was like a girl that
was like back at home watching corey's
uh dog
so i guess she's just a friend
i'm not sure um i mean she had the keys
so
she got the keys i'm dying i'm dying
i'm telling you there's something not
right there i just
really like
she really likes corey i don't know if
that's her type outside of the villa she
didn't describe it like that but
okay
well i have another question for you
guys since so many of us were just like
really up in arms towards the end we're
like why are we watching this like bring
back janet hashtag where is shannon did
production ever reach back out to you
about like coming back like because you
would have won
yeah no they honestly didn't we were in
contact with them all the executive
producers everybody involved the show
they kept reaching out to me to make
sure i was okay that's really the
support from the show has been amazing
um flowers yeah that's so nice multiple
different people sent flowers from from
the production and it was just
unbelievable they never once asked if we
could come back but they were just
making sure we were okay we got back
okay okay you know if we need anything
they were awesome in that sense but no
they never asked if we want to go back
on the show i think it's like kind of a
fine line right there yeah and i don't
know if that was in our contract like if
you leave the villa if right
there is so much also
i'm sure it would have just been too
much yeah yeah plus like the status of
josh they weren't probably like hey can
we actually i didn't want to be cruising
right and there was already
there was only like 10 or 11 days left
of filming right so it was close to the
end so it's like by the time you know me
and my family got together we were
mourning we had my sisters awake and
then
if we really did want to go back they'd
only be like three days two to three
days left to filming so didn't really
make any sense yeah and it's a lot of
traveling too torture i'm sure yeah um
okay let's dive into another
controversial hot topic and that's the
will and cure of it all
um because aside from you guys they were
like the longest lasting couple but
there's just been so much weirdness and
the reason why i asked you if you would
watch the show afterwards was because he
had like a similar confrontation with
trina that he did with you obviously it
wasn't as like dramatic but honestly i
was so supporting you i was like
everyone's like shannon took it too far
i'm like she didn't take it far enough
like i have so many questions about will
and kira but i was wondering if you had
any thoughts on the conversation where
he had with trina where he called her
manipulative just because she was
expressing concerns to kira
so i we did not watch but we did see
clips and then trina actually talked to
me about that so she did film me in a
little bit like kind of like all right
yeah with the will thing like he called
me manipulative and i was like wait what
are you talking about clearly i did not
watch that episode we're still catching
up um but i think that
you know like i said people's true
colors really do come out you can only
put on a fake happy face for so long and
then if your true colors do come out and
then it's like okay well maybe that was
just like a one-time thing maybe
you know you always give them the
benefit of the doubt and then when it
keeps happening it's like okay that's
actually who you are on the outside
right you cannot hide it on on camera as
much as you try to so when me and jackie
were recapping the show it was very
clear that there was something about
will that p made people not trust him
yeah and it was this kind of thing we
couldn't put our fingers on and i'm
wondering if you guys can explain like
why did so many people have reservations
about will what was he doing or saying
that made you kind of wary of him
from from a guy's perspective and i
think some of the girls had said this to
me was like
i mean even from day one when we had a
conversation about him i mean he was one
of my good friends in there but also
there was something and i think i said
it on camera i was like there's
something i don't trust about him
um and i don't know if that's true or
not but he would just sort of look at
every girl and you know kind of talk to
every girl like they were his girl yeah
and i think that's what rubbed some of
them the wrong way was like obviously i
i was friends with all the girls but i
wouldn't treat all the girls how i would
treat channels
not appropriate right at all so i think
he would sort of you know lead some
girls on and flirt with some girls and
that's just from their perspective
telling me um but i think maybe that's
why
i don't know i just feel like i'm a very
like powerful strong woman like i come
off very
tell it how it is and you can tell that
like
some
men do not like that um they don't want
that in their life they want somebody
that's a little more submissive or like
they're just different and i think i
kind of saw that and will and got so
frustrated because kyra is one of my
good friends and she is such a strong
woman but like she needs like a strong
man to bring that out of her not like
kind of
and i don't want to say that because
we're really good friends with will and
karen now that the show's like over and
everything and that was obviously just
with the drama but
um
yeah
did your fight with will hurt your
relationship with kyra at all
yeah it did
um there was some things that will said
to me off camera that were not allowed
to be aired no way yeah and i'm not
allowed to talk about them wow
but it did involve you know hr and it
just wasn't hr
yeah uh so
where is hr in the villa are they in the
different house they're just called then
i think
i'm not even sure yeah interesting
but that's why it looked like i was like
stop talking to me stop talking to me
right right right because of the things
that he said that they weren't allowed
to air um made me look like i completely
popped off right which watching the
episode back i was like
okay so i'm the crazy [ __ ] i didn't
even think he popped off so hard i'm
like you should have went harder like he
needed to hear that he was just like
coasting around doing whatever the [ __ ]
he wanted yeah acting like like a dick
and somebody had to put him in his place
and janet was was the one to do we were
joking around the entire show saying oh
it's it's will island it's not love
island like he would just do or say
whatever whatever that's how he would
like treat it and it's like no sit down
yeah
we're just living in it but they're
still together correct
have they watched the episodes i don't
know no
they have been do you guys feel weird
like watching the episodes yes yeah yeah
right i don't even watch my own podcast
we figured we wanted to watch them
together especially the time like the
beginning yeah but after a while you
guys were just coasting like being funny
yeah yeah like those episodes are fun to
watch yeah for sure um and the other
thing about will and kira is this
obviously everyone's wondering about
this conspiracy theory that they knew
each other before the show i've heard on
the instagram lives amy and wes who are
so bitter and i'm with them like they
should have been there they were a great
couple they're obviously very bitter
that they
got sent home and they're just like
saying that you know kieran knew where
the house was she knew who everyone was
like she got the 411 on everything and i
don't know if i believed it but then in
the final episode i don't know if you
guys caught this they were just talking
about how this journey's been so crazy
and like how wild it is that they live
15 minutes from each other but they
never knew each other which is just like
you live 15 like it's just a little too
coincidental yeah so what do you guys
know
i don't even know if we know for sure
and because we didn't have access to our
phones we didn't even know that was a
rumor going around inside the villa so
until right after because it's not like
hey did you guys know each other
somebody said that on the outside yeah
we have no idea what y'all are saying
about us while we're in there wasn't it
like leslie's grandmother that yeah
when she came into the show and like you
guys were at casa she had mentioned it
to us and we were like wait what she's
like yeah my grandmother did some
digging and yeah they liked each other's
pictures from like months ago that was
on like reddit and like these blogs and
i guess grandma leslie
read the blogs told leslie leslie came
in with the info but there's no way of
knowing if those rumors are true exactly
i mean i could i could see them knowing
each other totally i can see that i just
we haven't talked to them about it also
you know how like when you follow people
and like you just like their pictures
but you don't actually know who they are
but how are they following each other
just from social media i know that
happens that's way too ironic it's too
much i agree with you but it could
happen it could i'll give him the
benefit of the doubt yeah like the pope
accidentally liked one of the that girl
the port stars
no yeah yeah complete accident complete
accident right
um okay who are you guys closest with
from the villa in terms of friendship
um i would say cash for sure for me um
we just have like the same kind of
personality vibe where like
we bounce off of each other and like we
brought things into the villa like our
singing and the singing yes everything
that we do with our friends back at home
i was like wait i do that she was like
no i do that and i was like
well the thing is is like what i loved
about the show when i was first like
starting it was like of course it's fun
the drama but like there really isn't
that much drama it's just fun to see
female friendship and you guys are like
so funny singing and dancing and it was
like the best part and then when you
left there was like such a hole and then
right after cash left and i was like oh
this is not gonna cut it like all of the
personality the singing the dancing you
guys were being so funny that
magic was gone and it was really hard to
watch after you guys left not to like
blow so much smoke up your ass but i'm
telling you
i'm telling the truth i really
appreciate hearing that and what do you
guys think about cash and cinco like
i like you they're like together right
yes they are together um we're going to
see them right after this yeah
i think it was just he was just confused
like it was always cash yeah i think it
was just his judgment was a little
clouded and we both kept making like the
wrong decisions yes yeah yeah it was
like wrong place right person wrong
place right yeah at least they figured
it out though let's really quickly talk
about the jenny of it all because that
was like a really painful couple
episodes that she appeared in um and it
was just so weird because you knew her
and i'm just gonna assume that you guys
are still not on good terms if from what
i've seen on social media we are not i'm
just going to leave it at that um
yeah i hate talking about jenny because
it just gives her more clout moving on
people
people like anyway people like leslie
and you know fenevive um they came out
of the show and were just like really
vocal about how like they got bad edits
like oh you didn't see this and you
didn't see that you didn't get to see my
personality i love philanthropy like
they just shut up
yeah we all didn't get good edits what
are you talking about so my
my question for you is like what are
your thoughts overall on how you were
quote unquote edited i think that
you know early on and you know they can
take bits and pieces of whatever like we
sometimes have 30 40 minute
conversations and they can only have an
hour of filming you have 24 hours of
filming all day yeah so i get it you
know um but i think that no matter who
you are like like shannon said before
your true colors are gonna show if
you're just you the entire time they
can't edit you a certain way because
you're not letting them yeah so like
after it came off like a douche bag like
the whole kind of but not really yeah
the lifeguard challenge like that never
really
oh that was really [ __ ] up that was
really [ __ ] up thank you for bringing
that up i was so upset at you
did it actually happen i'm so mad at him
we saw these fans yeah it did actually
happen but that's it was so [ __ ]
uncool josh like no it wasn't him it was
a plan there was there was a lot that i
can't talk about but i'll just leave it
at that i was so upset with you like i
was like this is not i am you're jewish
right goldberg goldstein goldstein same
thing
i like to tell people i'm like this is
not my jewish king there's no way he
would do that to shannon oh my god very
uncool no i agree i i felt bad and i
apologized to her afterwards there's a
lot there's a lot that goes on behind
the scenes i'm sure i'm sure i know what
you're saying um okay now i want to
quickly segue into a section that i'm
calling logistics because i have so many
questions about logistically what it's
like to live in a house on an island on
a tv show so just i'm gonna rattle them
off and you let me know what it was like
towards the end of the show i really
felt like a lot of people were getting
sick of each other and like everyone was
just like i cannot wait to get the [ __ ]
out of here
did you guys experience that at all
fatigue villa fatigue yes um you're just
constantly drained exhausted
sweaty
sweaty let's talk about that yeah did it
rain every single day every single day
pretty much yeah it's like location
third rainiest city in the world i think
we had no idea what
it mostly rained at night though the
days weren't that bad like you got sun
then as soon as the sun goes down it
would just be like
every like recoupling ceremony yeah
people thought it was fake water no it
was so annoying like you could tell
every time you guys were sitting on
those yellow couches that you were
moving in from the rain because that
part was covered and our hair and makeup
like hello you did your own yes
interesting did that room have air
conditioning yeah does the whole house
have air conditioning no just the
bedroom
the dressing rooms that's it so is that
why the veggies like always sitting in
the dressing room yeah yeah our dressing
room because it was downstairs it was
the coldest we would literally just nap
down there all the time because it was
so cold
the bedroom would be sweaty oh that was
that's another great question sweating
in the bedroom
yeah sometimes the air didn't work in
the bedroom and there's 15 people
sleeping in there and we're all kissing
each other and we're all like hot ac
gonna work and what how many days does
it take you to get a custom like i
cannot sleep like around other people
like i'm very self-conscious of like
myself how many days does it take for
you to get comfortable like just to
actually fall asleep instead of like
being awake the whole time like hoping
you don't like fart or something i think
the first night nobody slept right
that's just because new environment a
lot of people
um but i'm pretty i can like sleep
anywhere so like the second night i was
completely fine i slept like a baby
you're so tired it does not matter what
environment you're in or how many people
are what they're doing around you you're
you're hitting the pillow you're going
to bed right really yeah okay so drained
what about the groceries you guys were
always making fabulous meals who was
filling up the fridge
that was production or people that work
with the show like you would just ask
for something and then you could request
it would be yeah a lot of people like
amy was a chef a lot like giovanni would
request a lot of foods he would like to
cook like spices and stuff like that so
they would just ask and you know
obviously we're on an island so
sometimes it would take a couple days
but um it'd pretty much be there i
requested frozen pizzas it didn't get
them oh that sucks that's exactly what i
would have requested
and the whole kitchen's outside there's
no indoor kitchen no no
that's kind of like sucks like cooking
the heat it was cool though it was under
shade it really wasn't very hot
um now let's talk about the the daily
schedule because it seems like every day
you guys got dressed worked out then got
ready for the day was the working out
mandatory was it like a mandatory part
of the dancer i did not work out once
everyone put on workout clothes right in
the morning they would say like bikinis
or workout clothes so like i would just
put my workout clothes on and just not
work out
it looks so miserable oh my god all the
working out oh another good question
logistically we woke up and leslie was
gone first of all i don't know you guys
if you saw the episode they didn't say
anything they were just like good
morning leslie's gone moving on and i'm
like wait what it was just so random
because she was in the middle of a thing
with cinco like
we got no explanation and of course we
found out later on like she was smoking
pot or whatever um
from your point of view did you wake up
and she was gone or you had to say bye
you knew what happened we knew
yeah no we didn't get to say goodbye at
all actually like we were getting to say
goodbye but we knew it during the pizza
challenge
remember i didn't you did she was like
crying all day long it was like very she
wasn't crying all day long she was very
upset
something had happened and we were all
like what is going on nobody knew
and then we were the guys didn't really
know so we were chilling on the yellow
couches and then production came out and
was like so leslie's gone we didn't get
to say goodbye
that's crazy like is she gonna get sent
home is she not like she's like in a bad
mood all day like what's going on and it
was because she smokes pot
a vape well you don't have to say [ __ ]
you're not confirmed
of course of course um and i read
somewhere maybe it was one of your
guys's q a's or someone said there were
no clocks like you never knew what time
it was no clocks that's
crazy yeah it's like you're in a fake
world i would start like looking at the
sun i was like all right it's twelve
right it might be two o'clock what time
do you think you were going to bed and
waking up
i know we were filming to like four in
the morning the one day because the
producers were like
go to bed it's four o'clock in the
morning because they can't go to bed
where are you filming like you're just
sitting outside
like whatever they need to air like some
of the conversations after recoupling
stuff like that like the recoupling
nights definitely take the longest of
course so i mean we don't know what time
it was but it could have been like two
three four in the morning something like
that you have to stay in your same hair
makeup and outfit whether you're wet dry
have pizza sauce all over you it does
not matter you will be in that outfit
for two more hours after well speaking
of the recoupling jackie actually
pointed something out when i first
started watching the show she's like
it's gonna bother you and it bothered me
so much and
it's that the show refers to you guys as
girls and boys when you guys are grown
men and women or even girls and guys
like they never say but guys they only
say boys i know that's him yeah
and in your last most recent episode one
of the last that you were on you did
refer to them as guys and like it was a
groundbreaking moment and we're just
really grateful for that what the hell
is that
boys how old are you josh i have no idea
what how old are you 24 you're not a boy
okay i'm a grown ass man
it's so stupid and it bothers me so
it's so bothersome does it bother you it
is a little weird like i feel like we're
little kids
being babies in school that's what it
kind of feels like when you're in the
villa like yeah being babysat yeah all
the time don't get me wrong it was an
unbelievable experience like it was
worse that's not me [ __ ] on the show
no i'm just a negative person so that's
why i'm only asking negative questions
but i have a few more yeah um were there
any actual physical like cameramen or
was all cameras like hidden in the house
and stuff or were people following the
majority of the cameras like the smaller
ones were just mounted everywhere they
had like 360. but there was like four or
five like big cameras that you would
have like your main conversations with
and that was man-made or man held yeah
it was like there's like a whole
perimeter that they would have um around
the villa
is that just so weird like
the camera's everywhere like i get you
oh yeah that's the shower singing and
stuff too the shower there's one shower
one shower
two shower heads so two people well the
girls were just awesome well that's not
a big deal but i saw like a scene with a
couple guys in the shower and i was like
are they sharing a shower yeah i mean i
put jeremy would always like follow josh
in the shower no he wouldn't
know he went but i saw jeremy and
florida hanging out like what about
jeremy and bailey cause i voted for them
actually no i voted for charlie and
elena bailey will be here this weekend
too we're all is she i'm pretty sure
yeah yeah i liked her are they
still an item him and her i actually do
not know i haven't asked we're going to
find out right after this podcast let me
know because they were florida and
jeremy were together it was very common
yeah she flew in last night to new york
i think and jeremy's from here so yeah
giovanni was there too i think what do
you have to say to the fact you know i'm
not going to ask you guys i got in
trouble um
where does arielle live
does she stay in the villa
she stays at the hood in the hotel the
whole time or she goes back and forth
she just pops she just pops in like when
it's her time dream job right yeah she
has the best life she does she's amazing
honestly what was she like
stunning stunning
even more beautiful in person which is
hard to believe oh my god yeah she's
awesome when she came out in that cat
costume
i go i'm packing my bags and i'm i'm
leaving if another blonde i was like i
was like arm around shannon and when she
came out i was like josh was like
yeah sorry babe guys that night was the
best episode of tv i'd probably ever
seen first of all everyone was just
showing their element like cinco and
cash were like really like just vibing
and like olivia and corey were finally
like doing something it was just the
best episode and then arielle came in
like everyone's like is that a girl it
was just the best episode and then
that's the night literally everyone went
home and it was just like so it was
it was the arc for me like after that
things started to get bad we have no
idea when people are like going home or
when there's a recoupling they do not
tell us we started to catch on we're
like okay as soon as we're having one
night with like so much fun
people are gonna die
when you get a party yeah exactly like
something's gonna happen so um okay my
last question for you i just wrote this
oh when you guys got back how many text
messages did you have on your phone i
still haven't gone through all mine i
had like 150 unread still i'll get back
to you guys i promise four thousand
that's texas crazy something like that
yeah so all in all describe the
experience obviously you're glad you
went incredible i mean really the
producers are so there for you like on
the show like they are like your family
you don't have your family and your real
friends back at home you cannot talk to
anybody you cannot talk to your mom if
you want to
um it's really hard so for them being
there for us all the time really really
i don't know what i would do without you
know production wasn't there like really
helpful and like or you felt like they
were trying like a lot of shows they
really set you up like they're not your
friend yeah they could have totally
turned against us and been like
do this or do like whatever they were
very also made sure that we were
comfortable
they were happy
they were really there for us they
realized obviously we're real people and
like we do have like our own lives yeah
we can't like control everything that we
do obviously we're adults so they were
definitely there for us they want to
make sure we were okay you know mentally
physically because it is a long draining
process is there a therapist on
there has to be right yeah oh yeah yeah
did you guys get um like you have to get
std tested before you go yeah yeah so
many times yeah so many times background
how did you guys get scouted for the
show
instagram no way yeah i love that
everybody got
sought after for the show and actually
you know things do come full circle
because my sister signed me up behind my
back for the show
no way and i was seeing everyone oh my
god i've chills yeah yeah it's crazy how
this world works like i was the only one
that actually applied to be on the show
um you know i got on and you know
everything comes full circle and i met
you know shannon so oh that's beautiful
that's crazy oh my god i love that
that's really sweet thank you for
sharing that yeah of course well thank
you guys for being here i'm so america's
just so obsessed i'm so obsessed you
guys are so nice and fabulous and pretty
in person like your eyes are so blue and
you are just like so tan and stunning um
thank you you guys just need to start
posting more on instagram like i'm
always checking your instagrams like you
literally haven't posted in three days
what is that
we post a lot on our stories yeah i know
but i mean
i came from like 2 500 instagram
followers so i'm still trying to like
how many do you have now like 185 000
what are you trying to get used to it um
250 000. i think that's crazy it is wild
yeah so like we have to like actually
think about what we're posting now yeah
just like i don't have content really
good content to post because the
pictures getting them off the phone from
the villa is so time consuming do you
still have the villa phone with you
i wish there's so many great photos that
of josh and i that i really wanted to
post my instagram and i don't have
access to them oh that's so annoying
were you not able to text them to
yourself before you left i would so
those phones aren't connected to
anything anything so it's only to take
pictures and videos and they change the
time and all that stuff in the day they
do and
it was like halloween on his phone in
like december on my phone yeah and when
you guys are now just like laying in bed
and someone texts you do you say i got a
text or you just say hey i got a text oh
as soon as i we scream as soon as
as soon as i came home there's probably
like a hundred people at my house and
they made me someone sent me a text they
made me say from there can you guys say
it for me please three two
one
yes that's a great way to go into the
weekend thank you guys so much for being
here follow them on instagram they're
going to start posting thank you guys
for listening to the morning toasted
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heard a
cat box all the places wherever you
listen to the podcast find out this
morning until the five star review about
a beautiful stunning and smart we are
and if you're still listening to this
episode leave a little palm tree on our
instagram in honor of love island have a
great weekend you guys uh don't drink
and drive bye please go check out the
link in my bio for my sister it's a
great keep going yeah it's a great cause
tell us about that yeah so she did a lot
of work for the community she was a
social worker and you know it helps the
less fortunate uh find housing or find
whatever so um please go hit up the link
in my bio and donate to a great cause
for my sister so thank you guys thank
you for sharing that you guys yes
yes have a great weekend we'll see you
on monday we love y'all thanks for
having us see ya